et notre dossier à présent retour sur un
procès hors-norme sept jours d'audience
aux assises mais sept jours qui n'auront
pourtant pas permis de percer les
secrets de nordahl de landes et le
meurtrier du berrichon arthur noyer a
été condamné mardi soir à 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle
antoine dernière céline durchon 9 heures
ce lundi matin nordahl le landais arrive
la famille d'arthur noyelles patiente au
complet
le portrait du jeune caporal trône
devant la cour il pourra pas mentir sans
se contredire
carter sera présent dans le box un ordaz
le landais a prêté soigner très calme et
qui annonce dès ce premier jour que oui
il a tué arthur mais sans jamais avoir
voulu lui donner la mort il répond aux
questions il est poli les ne coupe pas
la parole voilà c'est exactement le
propre du manipulateur
journée chargée
l'audition de plusieurs témoins des
proches de l'accusé ses ex compagnes et
compagnons qui dépeignent un homme banal
normal alors certains se sentent
responsables de n'avoir rien vu deux
témoins sont partis avec un sentiment de
culpabilité et je trouve ça dommage
et s'il est que s'il nous écoute je
voudrais leur dire qu'ils ne sont pour
rien dans la mort d'arthur
des témoins toujours ceux qui ont croisé
arthur cette nuit là il sort ivre de
boîte de nuit se fait voler son
téléphone par deux individus
une heure avant de croiser la route de
l'accusé il est alors 2 heures du matin
et véronique lui vient en aide
il était très calme il était pas
ils n'étaient pas énervé n'étais pas en
colère de ce qui vient de se passer
enfin façon c'est ce qui m'a dit je
n'aurais rien pu faire dans les termes
il était même moi j'avais consciente et
de briquets il en a pas plus d'effets en
hockey marc mercier un nombre de fois
incalculable et donc en partant quand
j'ai dit bon écoute prends soin de toi
qui vois là il est plus ma femme ça m'a
surprise ça m'a touché les trouve ça
trop mignon quoi un jeune homme calme
jovial et galant qui veut rentrer à la
caserne récit crucial pour la cour et
bouleversant pour la maman d'arthur le
témoignage de la barbanne et qui m'a ému
parce que je voyais artur mas je le
reconnais c'est donc tous prédisaient
l'interrogatoire de nordahl le landais
il maintient tout arthur pris en stop
agressif à tel point qu'au moment de le
déposer le jeune caporal lui assène des
coups de poing une bagarre éclate arthur
s'effondrent les nordahl le landais
dépose le corps à l'abri des regards
même son avocat l'a poussé à dire la
vérité mais rien n'y a fait plaidoirie
réquisitions sept heures de délibéré et
à 23h30 le verdict 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle assortie d'une peine de
sûreté de treize ans et voilà voilà bien
ça méritait pas davantage et c'est ce
qui a été prononcé
voilà justice a été rendue nous on
voulait que que la société que le
système que que tout le monde reconnaît
tous fait un meurtre que notre fils
était elle a été victime
c'est fait voilà